immer mehr bestätigte corona infizierte
in deutschland über 1000 menschen sind
in quarantäne
wie umgehen mit dem neuen virus wie groß
ist die gefahr
darum geht es jetzt in diesem zdf
spezial herzlich willkommen
jeden tag werden jetzt neue corona fälle
in deutschland gemeldet daran werden wir
uns wohl gewöhnen müssen
die meisten infektionen gibt es nach wie
vor in nordrhein westfalen vor allem im
kreis heinsberg die straßen dort sind
wie leergefegt nach dem ausbruch müssen
viele menschen vorsorglich zu hause
bleiben
über die aktuelle situation berichtet
adeus parade ortsmitte gangelt
epizentrum der chor ohne infektionen in
nordrhein westfalen rund 1000 menschen
leben hier nun isoliert in häuslicher
quarantäne
auf den ersten blick merkt man davon in
den straßen nichts alles scheint normal
doch das thema corona ist allgegenwärtig
auch in diesem imbiss das
desinfektionsspray steht griffbereit
dennoch klagte besitzer das kaum noch
einer zu ihm komme dieser moment haben
wir nichts neues problem wo sie da
vielleicht wir haben gestern
weggeschmissen aber wir haben gewisse
alles wegschmeißen personal strom das
ist nix jetzt bot die verunsicherung
gross immer wieder kursieren gerüchte
gangelt soll zum sperrbezirk werden
eine solche maßnahme ist von den
behörden vorerst aber nicht geplant
dennoch die zahl der korona infektionen
steigt weiter mittlerweile gibt es im
kreis heinsberg offiziell 35 infizierte
personen schulen und ämter bleiben
weiterhin geschlossen
in hamburg beginnen heute die
frühjahrsferien in der nacht wurde der
erste corona fall der hansestadt bekannt
in den schlangen vor den
check-in-schaltern am flughafen das
gesprächsthema
beunruhigung verunsicherung angst alles
zusammen wir haben jetzt masken dabei
das infektions wird der handschuh und so
weiter einfach als schutz damit wir auf
der sicheren seite sind und in hamburg
geht es ja gut los von daher gut dass
fliegen
ankommende passagiere aus den am
stärksten von corona betroffenen
regionen sollen so genannte aussteiger
karten ausfüllen damit sollen bei
möglichen infektionen alle betroffenen
reisenden schnell ausfindig gemacht
werden
das aber klappte zumindest am abend noch
nicht öffentlich befragt worden
wir sind hier in deutschland nicht nur
länderweise ist einmal fieber gemessen
worden
das ist in italien gemacht worden als
durch eingegangen bisschen gesprungen
sind und bei dem ersten bestätigten
corona patienten in hamburg handelt es
sich um einen kinderarzt aus dem uni
klinikum der stadt der mann hatte urlaub
in norditalien gemacht in einer gegend
die nicht als risikogebiet eingestuft
ist er war vergangene woche montag
wieder zum dienst erschienen fühlte sich
ab dienstag krank und ging nach hause
er hat sich dann am donnerstag testen
lassen weil er besorgt war
dieser fall hat dazu geführt dass heute
in allen hamburger kliniken viele
menschen mit angeblichen corona
symptomen ankamen
viele junge patienten sind tatsächlich
kommen liegt wahrscheinlich auch an
zeiten karneval war letzte woche
sie vermuten irgendwie kontakt zu haben
sie sind beunruhigt vier patienten sahen
sich die ärzte genauer an allerdings
ohne befund kliniken und ärzte verbände
raten ohnehin bei einem begründeten
verdacht zu hause zu bleiben und erst
mal telefonisch um rat zu bitten wenn
man nur leicht erkrankt ist und das ist
ja der überwiegende anteil der patienten
reicht es wenn man sagen zu hause bleibt
viel trinkt sich nicht belastet und
sagen darauf wartet dass der körper mit
seinen selbstheilungskräften die
erkrankung in den griff kriegt 50
patienten zum teil kinder und kollegen
des infizierten arztes des uniklinikums
bleiben jetzt 14 tage in quarantäne
entweder in der klinik oder zu hause und
noch ein weiterer oberarzt hat sich mit
dem corona virus infiziert in der
uniklinik tübingen in baden württemberg
und das ist ein grundsätzliches problem
medizinisches personal ist besonders
gefährdet und wird jetzt gleichzeitig
besonders gebraucht
wir konnten ganz aktuell mit den
betroffenen arzt in der quarantäne
sprechen uniklinikum tübingen
infektionsstation seit dienstagabend ist
er hier isoliert hans b einer der
mittlerweile zwölf corona virus
infizierten in baden württemberg per
telefon durch die zimmertür können wir
mit ihm sprechen
[Musik]
und auch geglaubt und wie sind sie
darauf gekommen dass infiziert sind
meine tochter war die woche so versuch
einer freundin in mailand und die
bekannte aus
sie kamen zurück
genauso wie mit den worten damit er das
virus nicht weiter verbreitet kenne
deinen feind das gilt auch für das
coruna virus doch dieser feind ist eben
noch sehr unbekannt kaum erforscht weil
er ebenso neu ist und das macht es auch
besonders schwer aussagen darüber zu
treffen wie gefährlich das virus genau
ist eines jedoch
oder diese woche immer deutlicher die
experten nehmen dieses virus sehr ernst
wird mittlerweile für gefährlich
gehalten als die grippe zumindest nach
den aktuellen zahlen
wie gefährlich ist das corona virus
wirklich des corona virus ist ein virus
das zu schweren krankheiten führen kann
wir wissen dass 80 prozent der fälle
sehr milde verlaufen das heißt also ganz
wenige symptome haben schnell auch
wieder gesunden wir wissen aber auch
dass rund 15 prozent der fälle von denen
die bislang bekannt sind schwerwiegend
sind das heißt die entwickeln eine
lungenentzündung und das sind immer
schwerwiegende krankheiten und an einer
lungenentzündung kann man sterben es
können natürlich alle menschen mit
vorerkrankungen schwere verläufe haben
aber insbesondere die älteren haben
zwangsläufig meist mehr vorerkrankungen
dazu gehören herz kreislaufprobleme
diabetes mellitus krebserkrankungen aber
auch schon sozusagen erkrankungen der
lunge copd zb das sind alles probleme
die letztendlich zu schwer wiegen
verläufen führen können ist das corona
virus gefährlicher als das grippevirus
das corona virus auf jeden fall
gefährlicher als die influenza-viren die
normalerweise in der saison auftreten
weil es erstens häufiger tödlich
verläuft als die influenza ungefähr
zehnmal häufiger zweitens ist es so dass
wir bei der influenza die risikogruppen
genau kennen
wir wissen dass alte menschen kranke
menschen und kleine kinder gefährdet
sind dass es bei corona anders da kann
es jeden in jedem lebensalter erwischen
und wir haben auch todesfälle von
menschen die vorher völlig gesund waren
und im mittleren lebensalter im bereich
des festlands von china und in den
zahlen die wir jetzt auf der welt sehen
haben wir zurzeit gehen wir davon aus
dass ein bis zwei prozent der menschen
die infiziert werden vielleicht sogar
sterben können
wie groß ist die ansteckungsgefahr
es ist tatsächlich so dass dieses virus
zu einem sehr frühen zeitpunkt
ausgeschieden wird das heißt also
menschen die auch wenig symptome haben
andere menschen anstecken können das ist
eine erkenntnis die wir seit wenigen
wochen erst haben
wie lässt sich das corona virus
eindämmen
was wir jetzt dringend machen müssen ist
wir müssen im land wirklich feststellen
wer diese virusinfektion hat und wer
nicht das heißt wir müssen
flächendeckend wirklich bei schweren
atemwegserkrankungen die aussehen wie
krippe corona virus tests machen nur
dann erkennen wir die krankheit so früh
dass wir sie quasi eliminieren können
die ersten krankheitszeichen eliminieren
können bevor es zum richtigen ausbruch
kommt nicht händeschütteln nicht um den
hals fallen keine küsschen geben
massenansammlungen eigentlich auch
vermeiden von kranken sich fernhalten so
ein guter abstand werden 1,5 bis 1 meter
das sind maßnahmen die jeder ergreifen
kann und das führt dann dazu dass sich
das virus nicht so schnell in
deutschland ausbreiten wird
und das wollen wir weiter vertiefen bei
mir im studio ist dr wolfgang kohnen
sie sind der vertreter einer leitung
leiter der abteilung hygiene und
infektionsprävention am uniklinikum
mainz herzlich willkommen herr kuhn nrw
haben sie ganz persönlich jetzt seitdem
das kroner virus auch in deutschland
angekommen ist etwas an ihrem alltag
geändert also zunächst einmal nicht weil
es ist grippezeit es ist eine zeit in
der man übertragen werden und hat man so
grund verhalten dass man an den tag legt
das ist also ende nicht so schütteln und
hat den ein meter abstand halten
nichtsdestotrotz ist es neues virus und
dann habe ich mir schon gedanken gemacht
muss ich jetzt mein verhalten noch mehr
verbessern und wir sehen ja die
ausbreiten nimmt zu auch entsprechend
reagiere ich also den ein meter abstand
halte ich jetzt etwas genauer an als
vorher
auch dieses fassen ins gesicht möchte
ich vermeiden ich mache sehr oft ja aber
man versucht das dann doch stärker zu
verringern
also das heißt sie machen ja jetzt schon
sie haben schon vorsichtsmaßnahmen die
viele leute sich jetzt vielleicht gerade
erst an gewinnen müssen und viele
menschen fragen sich was ist denn jetzt
zum beispiel am wochenende wenn die
fußballspiele losgehen kann ich ins
stadion gehen oder kann ich ein konzert
besuchen
wir haben jetzt zum beispiel gerade aus
der schweiz dass dort veranstaltung mit
über 1000 leuten verboten werden
das kann ich ihnen gar nicht beantworten
weil das von region zu region
unterschiedlich bin jetzt zum beispiel
in heinsberg wäre wäre ich
wahrscheinlich sehr vorsichtig oder wenn
ich bei auf einer veranstaltung bin
leute zu erwarten sind die das kona bios
tragen wäre ich sehr sehr vorsichtig
wenn es aber in regionen sind wohl nicht
viel passiert da würde ich gehe selbst
auch jetzt am samstag aufs
fußballspielen und ich denke das hängt
davon ab wie die gesundheitsbehörden das
beurteilen und dann der stelle muss man
auch wirklich malen dankeschön sagen an
die gesundheitsämter der zurzeit an
sehr sehr gute arbeit leisten und auch
solche bewertungen machen
ok herr doktor kunden wir vertiefen das
gleich noch mal
eines ist aber auf jeden fall klar die
verunsicherung die ist groß die telefone
in manchen arztpraxen stehen nicht mehr
still weil menschen angst haben sich mit
corona angesteckt zu haben
gerade die hausärzte müssen richtig
reagieren wenn ein infizierter dort vor
ihnen steht doch längst nicht jeder der
gerade mit einem hals kratzen in der
praxis auftakt gehört dort wirklich hin
julia schröter berichtet dass die zeiten
speziell sind merkt man schon am eingang
hand desinfektion damit patienten
möglichst wenig keime mit in die praxis
bringen nicht nur wegen corona sondern
vor allem wegen der aktuellen
grippewelle sind die schutzmaßnahmen in
der praxis von dr lemons in mainz gerade
ohnehin sehr hoch jeder persönlich hat
den schutz für tragen einen mundschutz
wir haben an schuldige bedarfsfalle
anziehen doppelt handschuhe
insbesondere dann wenn wir die patienten
näher untersuchen oder wenn wir
abstriche machen
zusätzlich zum grippe erreger breitet
sich jetzt das corona virus aus wir
wissen ja nicht wann die erste corona
verwendeten dann kommt hier bei uns
ankommt deswegen haben wir die
infektionsschutz maßnahmen noch mal
deutlich nach oben gefahren um uns
natürlich auch jeden einzelnen patienten
zu schützen
in der praxis mit zwei ärzten werden pro
tag rund 200 patienten behandelt in
grippezeiten auch mal mehr
wer besonders starke symptome hat auch
ein potentieller corona patient landet
gar nicht erst im wartezimmer
er wird leichen an den extra raum
geführt so handhaben dass viele praxen
diesem raum können wir die
hygienemaßnahmen besonders verhalten
lassen der raum ist bis oben hin
gekachelt wir können ihnen also
besonders desinfizieren sie wir suchen
den patienten dem er mutmaßlich als
infektions an stufen ohne wartezonen
direkt hinein zu begleiten dass er
wieder kontakt zu anderen patienten hat
noch großen kontakt mit unserem personal
hat das werden nach entsprechender
vorbereitung hier die gründliche
untersuchung durchführen können am
telefon fragen die helferinnen genau
nach symptomen und patienten schon vorab
möglichst gut einschätzen zu können
insgesamt sind die anrufe mehr geworden
die menschen gefühlt nervöser vor vier
wochen haben weniger patienten angerufen
als jetzt und die patienten gehen
inzwischen auch eher zum arzt als sich
ein bisschen auszukurieren
eine weitere wichtige aufgabe der
helferinnen der zeit sie müssen teile
der praxis immer wieder desinfizieren
die türklinken über die sich erreger
besonders leicht weiter verbreiten
werden jede stunde gereinigt glatte
flächen wieder tresen mehrmals am tag
die neuesten erkenntnisse zum corona
virus behält drm bands fest im blick und
informiert sich täglich bei den menschen
die zu ihm kommen erlebt er in bezug auf
das virus ganz unterschiedliche gefühle
das geht von panik angst um das leben
bis hin zum verdrängen und zum
kleinreden der eine sorgt sich dass er
infiziert sein könnte dass ein schnupfen
bereits bewohner wäre es ist und der
andere sagt ich habe 40 fieber ja und
habe ich jedes jahr dass eine so falsch
wie es andere sein rat keine panik aber
vorsicht und die empfohlenen hygiene
regeln beherzigen etwa das regelmäßige
händewaschen damit man am besten gar
nicht erst krank wird doktor wolfgang
kohnen ich würde jetzt natürlich auch
ihr rad interessieren was empfehlen sie
menschen die jetzt wirklich starke
erkältungssymptome haben aber die zum
beispiel nicht gereist sind und die auch
eigentlich keinen wissentlichen kontakt
mit einem infizierten hatten
wenn sie nicht gereist sind und nicht
aus regionen kommen wir gerade
risikogebiete sind und auch keinen
kontakt hatten das erste ist sich
erstmal entspannen die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass man dieses
neuartige coronaviren hat ist relativ
gering und dann je nach schwere der
symptome wird man das machen wir sonst
auch bei erkältungskrankheiten macht man
oft den arzt an nicht direkt hin laufen
sondern anrufen seinen hausarzt und
nachfragen abklären und eventuell wird
man dann einbestellt und man bekommt
entsprechend untersuchen
wie überträgt sich denn das virus
eigentlich ganz genau dass wir uns in
erster linie über tröpfchen übertragen
nochmals im rachen und es vielleicht in
tieferen atemwegen und dann wird das
beim sprechen zum beispiel wenn jemand
eine feuchte aussprache hat oder
speziell hatte ich beim husten oder
niesen übertragen so dass der normale
weg über den man sich schützen daher
kommt ja auch dieser eine meta ich will
den abstand haben auf der anderen seite
wenn ich nie ist musste bekomme ich
vielleicht auf die hände
ja und dann gebe ich dir an den anderen
und eigentlich ist am ende aber wenn
derjenige sich dann mit der hand ins
gesicht fasst und diese
infektionserreger in seinen rachen
bringt in seine hatten wege bringt dann
ist die übertragung bald abgeschlossen
dann geht es mal ausnahmsweise auch über
die oft direkt rüber zur nächsten frage
jetzt denken sicher viele mit
desinfektionsmitteln oder kaufen sich
ein mundschutz ist das sinnvoll
ich sage jetzt mal nein weil
desinfektionsmittel wenn sie im
normalfall die hände waschen dürfte das
reichen um die entsprechend coronaviren
abzuspeichern und natürlich sein dass
infektionen effektiver aber das häufige
händewaschen ist die erste pflicht
gemacht und auch vernünftig machen
sollten also vollständig die hand
benetzen und bei den bei diesem mund
nasenschutz würde ich auch zunächst
einmal davon abraten er kann sehr
kontraproduktiv sein wenn ich eine sehr
lange trage
und das macht man ja im normalfall dreck
den ganzen tag dann durchfeuchtet er und
sagen wieso feuchter filz und das ist
auch ein tolles tolle umgebung für
infektionserreger das heißt ich bekomme
dann sogar quellen gerade vor meiner
nase also regelmäßiger wechsel umgangen
dass ich auch in eng anliegen kann man
sieht man vorbilder dass das im mund
nasenschutz nicht richtig eng anliegend
und dann hilft er wenig man muss
wirklich gut damit umgehen können um den
haupt effektiv einsetzen
okay das merken wir uns dr wolfgang kuhn
ganz herzlichen dank dass sie heute hier
zu gast waren sehr gern händewaschen
nicht vergessen ist jetzt überall zu
hören das klingt erst mal banal hat aber
große wirkung weil sich selbst schützen
möchte und helfen will die ausbreitung
des corona virus so gering wie möglich
zu halten für den sollte mehrfaches
händewaschen am tag oberstes gebot sein
warum genau und was dabei zu beachten
ist zeigt anna lisa gaster ja
diese hände sind frisch gewaschen doch
sauber sind sie nicht all die hell
leuchtenden stellen zeigen hier könnten
immer noch gefährliche krankheitserreger
lauern
doch was ist hier beim händewaschen
falsch gelaufen und wo gelangen sie
besonders leicht auf unsere hände
bakterien und viren gehören zu uns um zu
unserem alltag
sie lauern überall doch bestimmte dinge
oder orte sind besonders dicht besiedelt
und es gibt regelrechte lieblingsplätze
für keime die uns auch gefährlich werden
können oberflächen die raucher sind
werden sie schlechter reinigen lassen
also richten die klubs sind und häufig
mit bakterien oder krankheitserregern
besiedelt sind natürlich dinge die viele
menschen regelmäßig anfassen das sind
ganz im vorrang beispielsweise türgriffe
lichtschalter öffentliche haltegriffe
ein weiterer typischer übertragungs ort
von bakterien und viren das handy
studien zufolge lauern auf einem
quadratzentimeter rund 4000 bakterien
trotzdem ist das immer und überall dabei
in der hand am ohr
neben dem essen die keime wandern dann
vom handy zum beispiel auf die finger
sauberer hingegen der toilettensitz denn
je wird meist regelmäßig und gründlich
geputzt auf einen quadratzentimeter
kommen nur etwa 3000 bakterien eine
echte keim schleuder türklinken hier
lauern pro quadratzentimeter bis zu 7000
bakterien regelmäßig sauber gemacht wird
hier nur selten
sind die keime einmal auf unseren händen
und werden nicht weggewaschen können sie
auf alles übertragen werden durch
schmierinfektionen wenn man sich zum
beispiel beiläufig an den mund greift
aber auch durch direkten kontakt zu
anderen werden sie schnell weitergegeben
gerade im winter haben krankheitserreger
dann ein leichtes spiel denn durch die
überhitzten oder geheizte räume trocknen
die schleimhäute aus und deswegen sind
wir gegenüber infektionserkrankungen
anfälliger dabei lassen sich grippe und
co in 80 prozent der fälle durch
richtiges händewaschen vermeiden aber
wie geht das mit dem hygiene techniker
oliver bahn machen wir in einem
einkaufszentrum einen versuch
wir wollen wissen wie gründlich sich
passanten ihre hände waschen
diese frau beginnt mit einer speziellen
waschlotionen wäscht sie sich die hände
darin enthalten ist eine fluoreszierende
flüssigkeit die keime simulieren soll
die wird nur entfernt wenn gründlich
genug gewaschen wird und tatsächlich
unter uv schwarzlicht werden noch einige
reste der flüssigkeit sichtbar
den volltreffer oder so ein bisschen hin
die insel nicht ausreichend gehör nicht
ich finde es ein bisschen beunruhigend
dass außen an der hand sauberer geworden
ist es an den handflächen und man
eigentlich alles mit anfasst manchmal
dachte ja wenn ich mit der fläche über
den handrücken streichen wird es ja auch
mitgewaschen erscheint aber nicht
ausreichend zu sein
aber wie wäscht man sich die hände dann
richtig wenn ich mir die hände wasche
dann sollte ich mir die hände waschen
natürlich mit seife sollte das eben auch
lang genug tun sollte die ganze hand
benetzen sollte auch die fingernägel und
zwischen den fingern auch die
handgelenke
mit waschen das sollte gründlich machen
was sollte ich mindestens einmal 30
sekunden darauf verwenden ein tipp wer
im stillen zwei mal das lied happy
birthday singt wäscht garantiert lange
genug dann gründlich abtrocknen am
besten mit einmalhandschuhen kandidat
nummer zwei erwischt lange und gründlich
lässt auch die fingerzwischenräume nicht
aus das ergebnis unter dem schwarzlicht
kaum noch rückstände von den simulierten
keimen also der fluoreszierenden
flüssigkeit er greift am liebsten
nur flüssig seite denn einfach weil sie
für mich praktikabler ist und
wahrscheinlich auch hygienische arbeiten
keine bakterien am zeichen klaus tragen
sammeln können stimmt das ist
flüssigseife hygienischer als fest zur
seife tatsächlich flüssigseife ist
besser weil keine hier nicht so leicht
weitergegeben werden können denn dass
seiffen stück bleibt nach dem waschen
feucht und das mögen bakterien und viren
gerne doch im eigenen bad kann man stück
seife benutzen dann aber regelmäßig ab
waschen und gut trocknen lassen und wie
wird der nächste kandidat seine hände
er ist relativ schnell fertig war das
wohl gründlich genug könnte nur ein
bisschen böser soll mit dem händewaschen
sind noch ein bisschen in zukunft also
lieber etwas mehr zeit nehmen aber wann
wäscht er sich überhaupt seine hände
wenn ich mal stadtraum wieder ankommen
oder wenn ich wenn ich dann ruhig mal
dass die hände noch so lange zeit
richtig aber es ist nicht so dass ich
sage wenn ich endlich angepackt habe
dann muss ich direkt wieder hände
waschen so viel muss nicht und wann
sollte man sich die hände waschen
man muss ein gesundes maß finden und
hier kann man durchaus sage ich mal mit
althergebrachten sprüchen der großeltern
argumentieren nach dem klo und vor dem
essen händewaschen nicht vergessen wenn
man das um den die situationen erweitert
beispielsweise nach der s bahn fahrt
nach der busfahrt nach dem einkauf nach
der benutzung von computertastaturen
dann ist man dann schon sehr gut
aufgestellt
wer das beherzigt und im alltag bewusst
mehr zeit und gründlichkeit ins
händewaschen investiert wird auf jeden
fall ein deutlich geringeres risiko
durch einen infekt einzufangen
der urlaub ist vielleicht schon längst
gebucht zum beispiel nach italien oder
nach asien und reisende fragen sich
jetzt ist das eigentlich eine gute idee
und wollen vielleicht stornieren oder
den urlaub zumindest verschieben aber
geht das so einfach welche rechte
reisende jetzt haben wenn sich das
corona virus am urlaubsort ausbreitet
zeigt torwart frage ob ein flug ins
ausland oder urlaub auf dem
kreuzfahrtschiff viele deutsche
überlegen ob sie ihre ferienreise
derzeit wirklich antreten sollen reisen
in zeiten des corona virus das sich
immer weiter ausbreitet wie halten sie
es damit
buchen sie noch oder studieren sie schon
meinen sohn wollte mit seinem vater nach
italien fliegen und her überlegen gerade
die reise abzusagen
ich glaube das machen wir ich habe da
keine bedenken weil ich auch weiß das
ist alles auch ein bisschen
hochgeputscht ist ob man auch wieder ein
bisschen runterkommen sollte ganz nah
also ich würde nicht hinfahren
warum soll ich mit menschen gefährden
noch so dachte auch helena ibach
eigentlich wollte sie gerade auf
geschäftsreise sein
doch nach norditalien zu fliegen dorthin
wo sich inzwischen hunderte menschen mit
dem corona virus infiziert haben das war
der lebensmittelchemikerin zu riskant
sie versuchte kurzfristig zu canceln die
rückmeldung war dann dass eine
stornierung halt nur für den vollen
preis geht das heißt keine erstattung
und nichts und die uns wurde dann
angeboten und angeboten das in umbuchung
tätigen können dafür mussten wir dann
pro person 150 euro 115 euro waren es
genau bezahlen umbuchungsgebühren
stornokosten anwalt michael habeck ist
experte für reiserecht kann ich vor dem
hintergrund des corona virus meine reise
nicht einfach stornieren
nur in ausnahmefällen sie das gesetz vor
dass man nicht auf seinen kosten sitzen
bleibt und das kann der fall sein jetzt
mit der voranschreitenden kohle epidemie
wenn man das schon so sagen kann ja die
reise im konkreten fall muss aber auch
erheblich beeinträchtigt sein
das wird also beispielsweise der fall
sein wenn mein hotel
unter quarantäne gestellt wird wenn ich
aber in einem noch nicht betroffenen
bereich bin
wer dieses niveau wohl noch nicht
erreicht so dass man auch eben kein
kostenfreies storno recht hat welche
rechte urlauber haben hängt auch davon
ab wie sie konkret gebucht haben
pauschal bei einem reiseveranstalter
oder anreise hotel und mietwagen einzeln
also ganz individuell aber
pauschalreiseveranstalter ist es so dass
ja die vereinbarung da ist das ein
reisemangel frei verschafft wird wenn
ich denn dann vor ort aber
beeinträchtigungen erlebe dort ist meine
reise ja mangelhaft und dann muss der
reiseveranstalter für abhilfe sorgen
und das muss er kostenfrei tun und das
habe ich eben nur im pauschalreiserecht
habe damit eine gesetzliche regelung die
es mir in bestimmten fällen ermöglicht
von der reise zurückzutreten
das habe ich bei 1 reist und nicht
jürgen und mariam scherner haben eine
pauschale flugreise gebucht
eine woche im türkischen antalya im
reisebüro fragen sie wie die situation
vor ort aktuell ist ob sie wirklich
fliegen wissen sie noch nicht
das ergibt sich erst wenn die beamten
warnung herausgeben
dann ist das einfach rennen aber
bedeutet eine reisewarnung dass keine
stornogebühren anfallen dürfen im gesetz
steht das nicht sagt unser experte
und doch erleichtert eine behördliche
warnung oft einem kostenlosen
reiserücktritt
die reisewarnung wenn die ausgesprochen
ist dann habe ich die sicherheit wenn
schon das auswärtige amt mich davor
warnt meine reise anzutreten dann kann
der reiseveranstaltern mir schlecht
verhalten ich hätte doch fahren können
wenn keine reisewarnung vorliegt dann
wird der reiseveranstalter natürlich
sagen wenn das auswärtige amt nicht
warnt warum soll dann der reisenden
nicht fahren viele urlaubsanbieter und
reiseportale preisen reiserücktritt oder
reise ausfallversicherungen an
doch bietet so eine police schutz in der
aktuellen situation was meinen sie
das geld wird anders ausgegeben
natürlich wenn die versicherung keine
reiserücktritts versicherung abschließen
als ich dann im zweifelsfall würde ich
das momentan einfach tun und dann wenn
man auf der sicheren seite für alle
beteiligten
doch genau das ist ein trugschluss warnt
unser experte die
reiserücktrittskostenversicherung
betrifft eher fälle in denen die
reisenden selbst erkranken deshalb die
reise nicht antreten können da
angehörige erkranken aber fälle wie sie
hier auftreten sind von solchen
versicherung nicht umfasst zurück zu
helena ibach sie hat ihre reise nach
norditalien jetzt umgebucht auf april in
der hoffnung dass sich die situation bis
dahin wenig entspannt hat und nach dem
urlaub geht es dann für die meisten
wieder zurück an den arbeitsplatz und
auch da stellen sich fragen was bedeutet
dass corona virus für berufstätige
welche rechte und pflichten haben
arbeitnehmer aber auch arbeitgeber
darüber möchte ich recht mit seiner
attacke leiterin unserer abteilung recht
und justiz hallo sarah wenn jetzt zum
beispiel kitas und schulen geschlossen
werden wie im kreis heinsberg und eltern
nicht wissen wie sie ihre kinder
betreuen sollen dürfen die dann einfach
zu hause bleiben
nein dürfen sie nicht dass es ähnlich
wie wenn schleuser in der kita die
bundes hat die kita geschlossen wird
oder die erzieherinnen streiken
so ist auch wenn die kita wegen corona
virus geschlossen wird eltern müssen
dann für eine ersatzbetreuung sorgen
und wenn sie das nicht können müssen sie
versuchen urlaub zu nehmen oder sich
aber freistellen lassen vom arbeitgeber
wenn sie freistellen lassen bekommt sie
dann aber auch kein gehalt mehr
jetzt gibt es ja schon fälle da müssen
berufstätige in quarantäne bekommt man
dann weiterhin seinen lohn gezahlt ganz
klar ja und zwar ganz unabhängig davon
ob man einzeln in quarantäne genommen
wird oder ob man in die stadt in der man
lebt abgeriegelt wird man deshalb in
quarantäne ist dann bekommt man auf
jeden fall weiter sein lohn das regelt
das infektionsschutzgesetz und da steht
das erst mal sechs wochen die ersten
sechs wochen der lohn fortgezahlt werden
muss und danach wenn die quarantäne
länger als sechs wochen dauern würde
bekommt man krankengeld was passiert
denn wenn jetzt zum beispiel ein
kompletter betrieb schließen muss geht
das dann auch genau also auch wenn ein
betrieb geschlossen wird kann der
arbeitnehmer jetzt nichts dafür
sondern es liegt in der
eigenverantwortung des betriebs wenn sie
sagen wir wollen schließen aus eigenen
vorsichtsmaßnahmen und das gilt auch
wenn
jetzt staatliche stellen sagen betrieb
muss geschlossen werden und es ist das
betriebsrisiko des betriebs auch dafür
kann der arbeitnehmer nichts und wird
direkt weiter bezahlt reisen ist ja ein
großes thema daneben auch dienstreisen
wenn mein arbeitgeber mich irgendwohin
schicken will kann ich da nein sagen
da kommt darauf an in diesem fall aufs
auswärtige amt ab dass eine reisewarnung
ausgesprochen hat für den dienstort wo
ich dann wohl oder den reiseort wohin
geschickt werden soll
wenn dem so ist dann darf ich da nicht
hingeschickt geschickt werden das darf
mein arbeitgeber gar nicht erst anordnen
es widerspricht seiner fürsorgepflicht
wenn das auswärtige amt aber nur einen
sogenannten reisehinweis ausgesprochen
hat und das ist im fall italien zum
beispiel so dann muss man abwägen
gemeinsam mit dem arbeitgeber geht es in
eines der gebiete die betroffen sind
oder doch woanders hin
dann kommt es darauf an und dann muss
man sich dann besprechen mit seinem mit
seinem arbeitgeber haben berufstätige
die sich jetzt sorgen machen in
irgendeiner form ein recht auf home
office 9 also sorgen machen reicht nicht
aus damit man ins home office gehen kann
der arbeitgeber bestimmten dienstort und
nur weil man sich sorgen macht darf man
nicht zu hause bleiben weiter noch wenn
man dann einfach zu hause bleibt
riskiert mit einer abmahnung und am ende
sogar eine kündigung
aber wenn es corona fälle im betrieb
gibt dann hat der arbeitnehmer das
begründete recht zu sagen da will ich
nicht mehr hin und kann dann zu hause
bleiben und auch home office machen
ganz herzlichen dank zara tucker für
diese information gerne das komplette
unternehmen geschlossen werden müssen
das war in deutschland bisher nur kurz
beim bayerischen autozulieferer webasto
der fall
doch trotz trotzdem schaut die
wirtschaft mit großer sorge auf die
verbreitung des corona virus denn schon
jetzt sind erste auswirkungen spürbar
video-konferenz mit dem tochter werk in
china
beim ventilatoren hersteller ziel aber
ist dass gerade alltag
das mittelständische unternehmen im
fränkischen künzelsau kämpft mit den
folgen des corona virus viele der
chinesischen mitarbeiter kommt gerade
erst aus der quarantäne
allein durch die schließung eine woche
lang in der fertigung sind schon mal
zwei prozent weg spricht 2 millionen
euro durch jede woche die das virus
länger wütet und wir nicht die volle
belegschaft haben dieses an
signifikanten einfluss auf unseren
umsatz haben auch andere deutsche
unternehmen reagieren krisenstäbe und
reisesperren für mitarbeiter in
betroffene regionen sind mittlerweile
standard
viele setzen auf home office oder
videokonferenzen und drosseln
lieferanten waren und kundenverkehr das
problem china wo das virus am heftigsten
wütet ist deutschlands wichtigster
handelspartner
als abnehmer für deutsche produkte und
als zulieferer viele bauteile die hier
etwa zu elektrogeräten verarbeitet
werden kommen von dort besonders
betroffen sind die 5000 deutsche firmen
die in china tätig sind 75 prozent der
deutschen betriebe in china berichten
uns von umsatzeinbußen ein viertel aller
betriebe sogar von umsatzeinbußen von
mehr als 25 prozent das muss man sagen
ist ein schlag ins kontor
eine lage die sich noch weiter
verschärfen kann besonders abhängig ist
die deutsche autoindustrie die
mittlerweile 30 prozent ihres absatzes
in china macht andere branchen dürfte es
noch schwerer treffen
hinzu kommen mögliche probleme in der
luftfahrtbranche bei den
fluggesellschaften
und auch im tourismus allgemein wo die
verunsicherung auch nachhaltigere
zurückhaltung bei den konsumenten
auslösen kann
viele kunden überdenken jetzt geplante
reisen für das ganze jahr nach fernost
und auch innerhalb europas die lufthansa
zieht bereits konsequenzen durch die
airline überprüft alle geplanten
neueinstellungen streicht lehrgänge und
weite teilzeitregelungen aus
internationale tourismusbörse in berlin
steht vor dem aus eigentlich sollte sie
am vierten märz beginnen
der genfer autosalon 2009 10 noch so aus
in diesem jahr ist er bereits abgesagt
wie alle schweizer großveranstaltung mit
mehr als 1000 teilnehmern dass sich das
virus nun auch in ganz europa ausbreitet
heitz die sorge um die wirtschaft weiter
an in der autoindustrie die ohnehin
schwächelt könnte die krise noch mehr
jobs kosten
es laufen erste anfragen auf kurzarbeit
bei den arbeitsagenturen auch die
industrie selbst müsse konsequenzen
ziehen glaubt man beim interessenverband
dihk mit blick auf die lieferketten die
jetzt zu zerreißen drohen an der einen
oder anderen stelle dass man sich gerade
noch mal breiter aufstellt also dass
lieferantennetzwerk breiter fast das
soll produktion und lieferungen sicherer
machen
der verbraucher kann sich allerdings
sowohl auch auf höhere preise einstellen
und bei so viel unsicherheit rund um das
corona virus reagiert auch der deutsche
aktienindex empfindlich der dax rauscht
in den keller zwischenzeitlich mit einem
minus von fünf prozent fragen wir nach
bei valerie haller an der frankfurter
börse in frankfurt valerie das ist eine
historisch schlechte börsenwoche wird
das jetzt so weiter ja also ganz genau
weiß das natürlich keine aber das könnte
schon noch wochenlang so weitergehen
weil viel hängt einfach davon ab wann
der höhepunkte infektionen erreicht ist
wie lange die epidemie sich hinzieht je
länger umso größer der schaden bei
unternehmen und dem dax fakt ist solche
kursverluste gab es zuletzt zur
finanzkrise 2000
8 mit jedem tag wird klarer dass die
folgen der korona epidemie hier
angekommen sind und man fürchtet dass
deutschland in eine rezession stürzen
könnte von einer delle im ersten quartal
geht man inzwischen fest aus der dax zum
handelsschluss mehr als deutlich im
minus fast vier prozent seit montag hat
er damit gut 13 prozent eingebüßt und
steuert damit auf den größten
wochenverlust seit über acht jahren zu
das grenzt schon an panik anleger hoffen
jetzt darauf dass die notenbanken
einspringen und eventuell die märkte
stützen
der genfer autosalon wurde nun abgesagt
die internationale tourismusmesse
wahrscheinlich auch was bedeutet das
jetzt
das bedeutet dass die wirtschaftlichen
auswirkungen nun ganz konkret und
greifbar sind immer mehr unternehmen
melden ja auch probleme vor allem das
haben wir auch gerade in dem bericht
gesehen die touristik-branche
kreuzfahrten und flüge werden gestrichen
reisen reihenweise abgesagt
fluggesellschaften wie nicht nur die
lufthansa auch klm und easyjet und
andere legen schon sparprogramme auf und
auch die autobranche leidet ja weil
china nicht nur ein wichtiger kunde ist
sondern dort eben auch viel produziert
wird was die autoindustrie braucht also
und wenn lieferketten unterbrochen
werden dann betrifft das natürlich das
exportland deutschland ganz besonders
vielen dank valerie haller nach
frankfurt und das war es vom zdf spezial
zum corona virus vielen dank fürs zu
sehen hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
leute heute ich wünsche ihnen einen
schönen tag
[Musik]